hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar hi parameter sorting and
analysis using the bigfoot cell sorter i
am jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them entity ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the
presentation i'd like to now welcome our
speaker alan salek senior scientific
director the scripps research institute
alan you may now begin your presentation
hey guys this is al salek coming here
from scripps
all i can say is initially to start out
i'm not the biggest fan of webinars i
love seeing all your guys's faces
and the direct
back to back and the recognition of
whether what i'm telling you is being
processed
or there's something that obviously
needs further elaboration it's really
hard to do that when you're staring at
your own computer screen in your office
so bear with me on that i know at the
end we'll have some questions
and before i actually start this talk
let me just pop a little background into
how i'm structuring this talk
and what i want to make it about
initially when i was asked by thermo to
give this talk
i was really worried that i was becoming
kind of a walking spokes model for a
piece of instrumentation and i didn't
want to do that i didn't want to
just be a glittery brochure but rather i
want to tell some kind of story
and it turns out as i'm telling this a
story
it's a long story
and i'm not sure that all the parts of
the story can be told within this
initial talk
but first i want to
frame it in the context of what my
history with flow cytometry sorting is
about
and how we've gotten to
this
spot in slow history or we're doing
sorting based on spectral signatures so
i thought in telling that story it would
be best if i told it
through the evolution of all the
different
cell sorters i used over the decades
and how they've led to where we are now
because each of these instruments at the
time had unique stellar features
that were then carried forward in the
next set of instrumentation
and along that it also tells the story
about
how i
ended up
using different instrumentation from
different manufacturers what their pros
and cons were
and
why we're using what we have now
so with that in mind i have here one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
different
little epochs of instrumentation i want
to talk about and i'll go through kind
of each one describing how it helped us
at the time and what some of its cool
traits were
so starting i originally came to scripps
in 1998 under the
legendary joe trotter who many of you
know and that was quite
big shoes to fill both intellectually
and uh literally he's a big guy
and i had a great time under him before
he went to bd and i thank him
tremendously for helping open these
opportunities for me
so when i came over to scripts from
coulter in the late 90s
i was trained to use the epics elite
which is very similar to the bb fax
bandage
and their configurations were
three laser systems and the lasers were
a lot more
uh different back then to say the least
they were large water cooled ion lasers
that required
significant infrastructure and they
required tuning
but they were really powerful lasers
with great beam qualities and you could
tune them to different colors it gave
you a lot of inherent flexibility in
your systems and the original advantage
was an eight channel system you had the
classic two scatter detectors forward
inside but you had six pmts for
fluorescence detection that be could be
configured
off of the three different lasers
and that configuration also was another
degree of flexibility within the system
you could use
different
dichroic filters and different uh fan
pass filters so use different reagents
that were excited by the different laser
lines you're using so you didn't have a
real fixed configuration you would
typically adjust the system to optimize
it best for the user who's coming to use
it
and that was the norm for a while we're
all using the cellquest software but
this was back in the days of what i want
to call the lp record days we're still
using analog systems and just like a lp
record where you kind of hear the little
hisses and scratches in there there was
kind of built-in noise to the system in
the log amplifiers that just gave a
certain visualization effect to data
especially during compensation
and we didn't really realize that until
in 2000 we had the prototype bd hyper
fax i actually couldn't find a picture
of it because i think it's been buried
in the annals of flow history
but it was basically a modified fax
vantage
that had
digital acquisition interface such that
we're now taking the pulses
and digitizing them and i think at the
time was a 10 megahertz system
and
we had
labview as the software to use many of
these labware labview it was super
unstable
but off of those three lasers we're now
able to do eight colors and that was the
first i remember sitting i think it was
a 2000
uh cyto conference in
in san diego where mario asked who does
more than six colors and i was like the
only one to raise my hand that kind of
freaked me out a little bit but that was
the beginning we were now getting into
the land of digital and we started to
notice some very unusual things
especially when you compensated because
the digital system
remained true to the math of
compensation so the phenomenon of
spreading was never really visualized
before in the analog systems and all of
a sudden we're seeing that and we're
like what is this but one of the quirks
that was really interesting in the hyper
facts was there was no baseline
restoration if you compensated something
below zero that data just disappeared no
one really thought there was negative
space in flow which we kind of all know
now is there uh what do you think about
spreading environment by exponential
displays
so then came
the first official
digital system the bd fax diva diva i
guess standard stood for digital
advantage
and it was a three laser advantage it
was pretty cool because i had a switch
that can go between digital
or analog depending what you want to do
but along with it came some other cool
evolutionary features one was four-way
sorting so the classic two-way sorting
you could divert
up to two different populations to each
side giving them various degrees of
charge to affect their trajectory and
then you had the digital compensation
which was
uh
first
really
shown in a full commercial setting a
product that everyone could use
and that raised a lot of questions in
and of itself i remember when i first
there was another really prominent lab
that did a lot of flow here at scripps
that also had a vantage but they didn't
have a digital and when i first started
showing them some data especially
looking at some of the longer reds the
the pe57s and the apc size 7s were
spreading after compensation was very
evident they were just like what is this
you're
don't know what you're doing you're just
shilling for a company this doesn't make
any sense they were just so ingrained in
the classic
um
visualization of analog compensation
that they initially couldn't wrap their
head and i remember them telling me oh
you're just a shill for bd and i was
like whoa
no i actually think this is right the
math the math i understand it just
because this is the first company to do
it
doesn't mean you should poo-poo it
and that kind of taught me a lesson
there it's like wow people are really
ingrained in their habits and it takes a
lot of energy to change them
and so finally
once the education spread i was giving
lots of talks on digital versus analog
to explain it to people and explain the
the new fly exponential displays and
stuff like that people caught on but
that wasn't the only cool features with
this advantage one of the great things
was
the drop delay was automated and there's
a couple different ways to do it but
back in the old days we basically sort
puddles of beads or people do the ten
drop method there's all these different
very manual methods that was just one of
the big chores of setting up this order
but for the first time bd had their
sword check beads where you could
deflect look at the total amount of
deflection versus what was in the center
stream and say hey i've peaked my i've
optimized my delay because i can see the
deflection is working was a great visual
way to look at it and you'd use your eye
and with these systems we got up to
eight colors so so that was pretty
awesome we were impressed with how well
this this was starting to work and
digital eventually did come on but these
were still classic open architecture
sorters with a lot of hands-on and
required a lot of input from
the
the operator
then in 2002 this was a big game changer
the fixed alignment sorter there was
this order you could just walk up
turn on the button
and it was basically almost ready to go
it used that same kind of um
timing for the sorting you run qc beads
it was just a really really cool system
and it had fixed alignment with this
hybrid nozzle that
the cell went by cuvette before it was
spit out at the tip
and it was a full digital system and it
was getting they were getting more and
more advanced our first one was a ten
color with three ways and eventually
these things matured to buy laser
systems
but we discovered something else in
doing this too and this was really
strange this was another great lesson
for a core manager like myself to learn
when we moved some experiments from the
vantage with its classic jet near novel
to the
aria
i had a researcher come up and say wow
this sort looks great
but my cells weren't proliferating the
same way they had before so they're
alive
but something slightly different is
impacting them and i'm like wow that's
weird and so we actually did a really
elegant experiment comparing
uh jet and air sorters to the
aureus order at the higher speeds and
notice that oh my god this is true we
did cfc saving for proliferation and it
turns out that there was something going
on and later we recognized that even
other publications we call it sorter
induced cell stress
and we did gene profiling to sure to
show sure enough it turns on a lot of
genes if you sort something in
conditions beyond it was meant for
but my big lesson was wow you can't tell
a big multinational company that their
flagship product doesn't work like
they're expecting it
and i caught a lot of
negative vibes
by presenting that to bd
and
bd in their own way acknowledged it by
making a change of design but they never
really
acknowledged that yes i i had seen
something they tried to say it was
my fault and blah blah blah but they
behind the scenes slowly changed the
design and the machine didn't have that
problem as much anymore but there was
still something there and it took an
extra level of kind of experimental
design introspection to make sure you're
not weren't sorting your stuff at super
higher pressure
okay so this was awesome the other thing
about this machine was it's
it initially signaled the end of the
sort operator because when they
initially
had it they were saying oh you can walk
up anyone can use it one button turns
out it wasn't there were so many little
quirks about the initial design that was
problematic that it took them years to
get it working sweetly
but it was definitely a game changer
with a super sensitive
sorter
that was really easy to set up that was
cool but because the researchers at
scripps
couldn't
recognize that there were some
proliferation issues
we ended up getting another new newer
digital system we took the
um
the cytomo flow platform and after
beckman purchased them
and we were able to repurpose our big
water cooled lasers it was really a less
expensive way to move on to
a newer platform and we started using
these systems and they were really cool
i mean they continued with the
multi-laser with the spatial delay they
still had the digital compensation they
did the sort dropped away in a slightly
different method they didn't use these
they used imaging they basically took
pictures
of the whole stream from interrogation
to last droplet and computed how long
that delay was
and uh i didn't believe it at first it
took a
few months of just manual verification
doing the old puddle methods but sure
enough that approach does work so
there's a couple different ways to skin
the cat of timing and this machine also
open architecture 12 color configurable
you put your own filters in it really
was a great workhorse machine
okay but then technology was evolving
along comes the first i want to say
turnkey automated sorter
to propel avalon at the timer now it
became the bio-rad se3
and that was a
nine channel it was super automatic like
you literally turned it on loaded some
beads on and it qc'd itself timed itself
it had little um servo motors that
aligned the nozzle it was pretty cool
and my original thought was this would
be um really popular on the user base
for self-service
but it turned out it was just not
capable enough to become popular in my
lab there wasn't enough channels there's
only two lasers they were co-linear
which is something i'm not a fan of and
you couldn't sort of full plate a lot of
people are doing the basic one color
sort or sorting on the plates but this
one had strips and while it was cool it
didn't really fit into the workflow of
our lab and i ended up donating it to
the san diego zoo where i believe
they're sorting rhino sperm on it
but then along came
the beckman astros this was basically a
repackaged evolved
version of the
moflow
but with a lot of really cool features
first it was five lasers all fiber fed
so the alignment was much more stable it
had the same drop delay by
image processing but one of the other
cool things was it kind of had an
integrated qc system you would tune it
it still has manual manual setup
required
but it would tell you you've passed qc
and all these channels so you set it up
correctly and you can go ahead and run
the uh drop delay automation and the
other cool thing about this drop delay
nation there was actual feedback that it
would adjust itself and try to maintain
its break off
and alarm you and shut itself off if it
did that was pretty cool the next cool
feature of this one was the six-way
sorting before i talked about four-way
now you can sort six three different
charge levels in two different
directions gave you six-way sorting
which is a nice tool that some of our
immunologists were using
but the thing i liked about most about
these two systems and the the buffalo
before it was improved plate deposition
it was
a very smooth piece of engineering with
like really fine
stepper motors that
was very accurate and that combined with
sorting straight down instead of sorting
a deflected droplet we instead would
bend
the entire waste stream to the right and
just sort whatever we wanted straight
down made it super accurate so we can
start doing 3d four-wheel plates this is
really cool so this is one of the
features of this piece of
instrumentation
that was
um
you know really useful in our hands in
the core
okay so we use these guys for a while
and then the next system we ended up
purchasing was
two of the sony systems and i remember
when sony first came into
flow and i was at one of the cyto
conferences i was like
oh my god the rounding error in sony's
budget is probably bigger than
you know all the other flow
companies combined
and they made a pretty good entry on the
scene
and they came out with the first order
sh they came out with some very slick
products
but they weren't super
high end and complex
okay in this case we ended up getting
the sony m8900 it has four lasers
two are collinear that kind of limits
some of the approaches we can do it
and
it's the first one to have disposable
chips and originally people were kind of
peeved by that a little bit but since we
bought two of them it turns out you
could use one chip on the other machine
you could double the life of your chip
usage and that worked really good in the
end you're only spending 10 or 15 bucks
a setup to run this and that worked
pretty good i was hoping to make these
user accessible machines like other labs
have but
um
the user base at scripps is just i don't
know if they're just lazy or just so in
love with our service that they would
rather have us do the work and just drop
their samples off so this machine is
really nice but what made this machine
super cool was the finish and i think it
came from
the sony consumer electronics
philosophy that everything worked really
nice the automation the finish the fit
it was all really cool the workflow was
really cool it was a well done piece of
instrumentation now it didn't have all
the traits of the previous instruments
so it just wasn't perfect so what i'm
going to do next is kind of go through
those little traits i talked about and
tell you what
i think i've watched over the first
decade and a half i mean having
spatially separated independent lasers
is a great thing
having configurable filters and
detectors was a cool thing too that
allowed us
with researchers who want to use novel
dies and stuff to kind of optimize the
system for that
digital signal processing i mean that's
just the way it is we all
20 years ago we looked at that like oh
this is some dark magic that i don't
know what it is now it's totally the
norm so i know given enough time the
user base is capable of evolving to
newer newer technologies the automated
qc and automated drop drop delay
determination that's all really cool i
mean you basically want to be able to
turn your machine on
throw some beads on
and let it go okay the the robust plate
sorting the use of 3d four-wheel plates
i mean that that's kind of key for a lot
of our research a lot of high throughput
screening groups want to be able to prep
a lot of their their compound studies by
seeding a bunch of 3d4 well plates with
cells and this this system works pretty
good and also finally like the slick
finish to make
the instrument look actually nice to
make all the interfaces and the
ergonomics really nice i mean those were
all these traits that led to where we
are now and where we are now is
and the whole point of this discussion
is at the time it was the propel bigfoot
the initial discussions were in in fort
collins in 2019
when i came in i called this instrument
the love child of the yeti analyzer and
the avalon sorter it had a lot of the
high dimensional features of the
yeti
and it had a lot of the automated
features of the avalon and it was all
put into one system so it was all the
inherited traits i described previously
and it had a pretty cool thing at first
i wasn't too sure about it had this
sampled paracel where you could load
multiple samples in there i'm like oh
who really does that you know when you
just it's not that big a deal to put a
tube on
but actually it turns out it's pretty
cool when you're running a bunch of
controls and stuff you just load them in
there and hit next next next next and
not have to stick your hand in there a
bunch of times that's pretty cool
it maintained a great plate deposition
system
and for us like i said doing
sort single cells into wells or seating
three to four role plays that's like an
important part of our workload so it
works great for that
and it had seven lasers and 56 detectors
and by the way when i saw that last one
56 detectors i'm like wow that kind of
jangled something in my head that i'll
get to in a second
but more than that there was two new
features i haven't i hadn't seen before
that i now realize are kind of
should be key going forward
one was the integrated bio safety hood
i'd never seen that before the whole
we were at the time a couple years into
what i call the hood fetish where every
single sorter had to be jammed to the
hood sorters didn't like being in hoods
the hoods were ridiculously huge and
expensive and it just didn't make a
whole ton of sense yeah i can't argue
that it nominally increased the safety
of doing this
but i feel like good ppe practice and
all those things before it was never
really that big an issue and then to
suddenly be decreed oh every sort or now
needs to be in a hood if anything's even
remotely
bsl
more than one
okay so
in this case the actual whole sample
handling area is in case of its own hood
if you look here i actually showed you
we had the
tss people come in and they actually
certified it so this is a functioning
laminar flow hood which is just a boon
for safety and the fact that it fits
into a relatively small footprint
instrument and doesn't affect
access and serviceability that's just
awesome i wasn't really too
i didn't think too much about it at
first when i saw but now that it's
actually part of our our lab and our
workflow it's it's great and i really
like it and another thing that i never
really thought of and i've seen a little
bit of before but didn't appreciate
until i really got to use it is
servicing the instrument
okay let's face it service is a
nightmare every single time a machine
breaks they'll inevitably do for
different reasons
you have to tell the service engineer
they have to come a lot of times they
come diagnose the problem don't have all
the parts got to wait for the part to
get shipped you wait for the part to get
shipped oh where is it is it receiving
oh it's on its way you just sit there
twiddling your thumbs for hours and
these these four guys are just
overloaded with work and it's a really
slow process
but now with this
new remote interface
basically you can sit on whether it's
zoom or team or whatever one you're
using on your on the
work screen of the sorter
and talk to those guys as they remotely
get in and interface with the machine
and
look at what's functioning here what's
not functioning there they have this
whole super complex user back panel
that allows them to diagnose the machine
remotely and a lot of times they can fix
it without ever even coming in or if
they do come in they already know what's
not working and the parts coming in with
them
and so with that
i think that has to be a trait that is a
part of all future instrumentation
because
the how many the amount of time we've
lost waiting for service just as a
function of reducing i'm making air
quotes optimize manpower and service
is uh is a burden on the researchers
okay so now i've talked a lot about
where i was when i first saw this
machine i'm like that's pretty cool but
i'm going to digress a little bit
because a few years earlier there was
what i want to call a disruptor in flow
cytometry
a few years earlier
we had spectrum of cytometry really
mature okay so spectral cytometry was
kinda
already there sony made a spectral
cytometer that was
it was kind of cool it was more of a
novelty it wasn't super cable there
wasn't a lot of lasers
but when i saw
the aurora came out
unlike
i think this is where flow is going
and in 2017 it says i purchased a five
laser 64 actually
prepaid for the five laser
and it was delivered to three laser
until the whole five laser system was
ready but even with the three laser it
was evident that wow this is
really where we're going in flow for
high dimensional stuff for 15 plus
colors it just looks great and the
workflow the software everything about
that machine just kind of works okay and
then finally
when um
they had the full five laser system it
was able to do 30 plus colors and i
realized
oh my god this is the the mass cytometry
killer i was
there was a lot of pressure from some
different groups to purchase a big mass
cytometry system but those are their own
can of worms you're going to end up
buying
lots of specialized reagents you need a
significant infrastructure to deal with
the heat from the plasma torch
it is a big complicated system
and it had its own inherent
issues too but now that
i saw the potential in this scitec i
remember there was one pi who came over
i'm like look i know you really want
a scytof give me a little bit of time
let's see where this does and right now
there's some of the biggest users of
spectral flow and and
it's really amazing right now it's
proliferating across the field
but the reality is our analytical
capabilities rapidly outpaced our
ability to sort and that's a big deal as
i was getting people who are doing 25 30
colors like oh i really wish i could get
this population in some cases they're
able to
work on their panels and drill it down
to something in the 15 color space that
we can do on one of our existing sorters
but they really wish they could do the
whole big picture where you could be
able to take
this super high dimensional view of a
sample
analytically and then if you need to
sort it
okay so now that i have this in place
let's go back to when i was first
looking at
that discussion in fort collins when i
said when i saw 56 detectors i'm like oh
man that's only eight less than the
aurora analyzer
and sitting in that that group of people
at that hotel meeting there's only one
other person
with any experience in spectral
sitting in that meeting and they have a
sony one
and i'm just like jumping up and down in
my chair i'm like why is this system not
spectral come on come on come on this
should be considered for spectral and
it's just crickets they're like trying
to give me this weird look i'm just like
okay whatever
so i guess for whatever reasons at the
time they couldn't tell me they want to
do spectral so tdar who was uh
in charge of propel comes over to san
diego and over the most delicious
falafel lunch we had at this great
little place he tells me yes they've
been wanting to make that thing special
but for every reason at the time they
didn't want to say it
and so he offered scripts to become a
beta location
and i'm like this is awesome the timing
couldn't be more perfect we have people
who are just right in position to do
this
and we're all ready to go
and then covet happen and that obviously
had other scheduling implications
and because of that we had to put a lot
of things
on hold
and it was
painful they delivered it just in like
early
spring like maybe two months after the
all the shutdowns happened it sat in
crates forever they weren't letting
anyone inside of scripts the research
inside of scripps became painfully slow
as it went to just sustenance level
uh like mouse colony maintenance
and then once
things started to ramp up it took a long
time to actually get the instrument
unboxed and running
and then the harder part was the
researchers took quite a while to
actually ramp up enough for this higher
level stuff
so actually where i went from having
people just lined up ready to do these
experiments
uh
i had like a really slow start
but luckily i had one guy who was in a
great position
and it was our buddy landon edgar he's
not university of toronto and he had a
great model he actually came from a mass
cytometry background doing high
dimensional stuff and making all the
reagents and he came over the scripts
having done no flow
and he was just brilliant picked up on
it right away and his model was looking
at carbohydrates on different phenotypes
it was a great a great model because you
could use classic uh immunophenotyping
combined with also co-expression of
these different carbohydrates and it all
correlated out really well in this high
dimensional stuff so here's the case of
him looking at all these different cell
subsets
and then
all these different cell subsets will
have different levels of expression of
these different carbohydrates and so you
could cross-reference all this and in
this perfect world we would be able to
sort it all
okay so let's
now bigfoot's finally working let's get
him to prep this and now i'm going to
touch on another part of bigfoot i think
is really cool
and it's
the way it's experimental design
workflow is integrated in the software i
really did was impressed by that
initially let me just talk about that
for a second so the workflow as you walk
on the sorter
it's all done with automation you
basically walk in the machine
hit start up
it'll tell you if your fluids are low or
everything's low whatever you put your
you put the juice in it hit one button
it says alignment qc
does the streams optimize the deflection
does the break off
optimizes the timing
and the delay and it's all done in a
one-click process
and it can be as black box as you want
it you can do it in one click and never
see or you can kind of get the more
service level menus and actually look at
the camera images of all the different
streams to make sure it looks good to
you there's potential that if you really
want to go down the weeds you can
optimize the drive frequency
combinations for better resonance and
get it to be a super super stable but so
far in our hands we haven't been having
to do that machine does a really really
good job
of
maintaining the stream
and that's that's basically the biggest
deal sorting i mean if you're not if
your delays off everything goes to crap
and uh we have confidence that for the
first time
that full level of automation
is really in one click is really working
great now there's a couple other
instruments that have that too and it's
and it's made flow a much easier or flow
sorting a much easier process
so next let's take a look at
um
the actual spectral workflow so we had
done the normal sort of stuff but now we
want to move into spectral space and
they have some cool features on this
system they have a panel builder you go
ahead and add your colors i'll talk
about that add your reagents and it
tells you
how complex it will be you know in a
perfect one
no way no colors spill into any other
colors and it's everything's super
perfect with literally no
uh overlap at all but we all know that
doesn't isn't the case so in this system
you
you
fill in the information the panel
builder run single controls for each one
as you go through one of the single
color controls it's like that's a good
control we'll be able to make a
computation based on that we'll give you
green check marks you just go through
the system doing that
and then the system
unmixes it
and plots it all out and now your
parameters are spectrally defined you're
no longer defined by a given filter it's
defined by the actual unmixed curve and
then you go then we would go ahead and
run the fully stained sample
set up our gates and we did a six-way
sword this is really a proof of
principle sort
there was some of the material taken for
downstream analysis but
this postdoc landon then actually got a
really nice position in canada and he
has since moved so we never got to do
the full follow-up on this that we
wanted
and uh that's actually one of the
hardest parts of doing this kind of
research is being able to test
a new platform
in a way that's actually scientifically
meaningful i mean there's you can do all
kinds of qc experiments but you actually
need to be able to do stuff that
benefits researchers otherwise it's
impossible to get them to do it okay so
now i'm going to go through and talk
about that sort workflow a little bit
more
so here's our panel builder and this is
another really cool thing too this is a
a
hodgepodge of
16 23 markers that we did on this one or
22 and live dead
and then they're from all different
manufacturers it's not like a given
reagent is constrained this machine can
only use these reagents which you've
seen in other instrument manufacturers
designs
this is ubiquitous
in that you can use whatever can
potentially work assuming that it gets
through uh
the next step so here's what all those
regions look like in a big combined
spectrum it's a big hodgepodge but more
meaningful
i'm sorry i did the wrong thing more
meaningful is
the um
the complexity
computation
and here we can see as we add the
different colors in the panel builder
that's a little blurry but i'll kind of
read it to you here it says here we have
a complexity of one a complexity of one
means nothing overlaps with anything so
as we start adding other colors the live
dead the bubs you see it start creeping
up intense little increments
and it works pretty good every so often
you'll see
a
one we get a big jump so using bv605 we
jump from 2.55 to 3.1 that's right the
biggest jump in the whole system in some
cases if we go from looking here from
bv786 to using 50 that adds no
complexity at all so we go through and
add these and then using alexa 532 adds
no complexity we go through and add
these different colors
and in the end we get a total complexity
for the experiment this is a good way
even before you run the sort
you can
kind of assess whether the degree of
overlap the predictive degree of overlap
in your
in your experiment and that's a great
workflow
okay so once we have all this plugged
into system the next step is we run all
the controls
as we run these controls it's just a
simple matter of running we're running
in this case beads and then um
cells for the y dead it basically said
this is a good control there's enough
positive
boom and we'll do that and it goes
through and it adds it into its little
calculation it tells you a green check
mark or yellow warning or red no that's
not working
okay so i'm not going to
dwell too much on
the actual
experiment because i showed this on the
cyto there was a cyto talk for uh thermo
and i showed that and this is all basic
sorting 101. we have our gates we have
viability we have waveform analysis to
do the doublet discrimination
and then we just went through a whole
series of gates where they're looking
for the
the t cell subsets with cd3
and
and cd11b negative cd3 cd48 positive and
then we can look for some of the other
classic t cell markers
of activated t cells on some of these
other cells so we can see yes this is
the t cell population we draw our gates
going through we do the same thing for b
cells nk cells same thing we get nice
discrete populations we got all our t's
now we have all our b's
and we have
our nk positive cells
and then we did dendritic cells we did
c11c positive we did neutrophils with
ly6g
and all these guys cross-referenced with
the predicted cyglic expression i didn't
want to pack this talk full of a bunch
of plots about this actual project i can
all that can be shown
uh later if you guys are interested but
i just want to show the proof of
principle that this thing actually
sorted now this is what's tricky
validating a sort
is a whole another project i think
running a sort and then re-running on
the same machine and saying hey look
everything fell in the case that works
great i think that's kind of a road to
painting yourself in the corner
a sort has to be
assessed on a separate analyzer to make
sure there's no inherent mix up in your
in your sorter configuration that's
leading you astray so what we did in
this case
was
we did this validation on the aurora
spectral analyzer and so our controls
were which were mix of the ultra comp
beads from thermos and cells were then
run on the aurora the unsorted cells and
sorted samples were analyzed based on
the same gates we used on the bigfoot
and initially in the talk i gave
for cyto two populations and genetic
cells and neutrophils were not shown
because there wasn't a lot of cells and
there was viability issues so for those
specific subsets
but what happened was there wasn't a lot
of dendritic cells but i'll show you the
ones we call pure
and the neutrophils just degranulated on
setting the other issue i have here is
when we're doing these things i can't
shut down my lab to the other
researchers to gain access to all the
instrumentation i basically was waiting
in line behind other
researchers who were using the aurora to
try to jump on so i could run our
samples so because of that
it didn't look as perfect as i wanted it
to but as i'm going to show you
it worked
okay so going through right here
we can see here's classic four and eight
okay cd4 wasn't one of our brightest
reagents but we still get a clean
definition of where it is relative to
the eight and sure enough when we look
at the aurora we took that little sorted
uh
bit of cells they came out as four and
eight i mean it sorts fine when viewed
on another platform we can go through
that's two of the populations let's go
through another two
i mean we look at the b cells sure
enough they all sort of b sales and when
you look at a sort okay it's 96
these are probably cells that died in
the waiting and this is probably the few
representative impurities or maybe a
little bit of passenger or something but
this sort worked we're not seeing
unusual distributions here to suggest
that the the delays weren't working
right
and same thing here as we go over to
the nk cells
sure enough on analysis they
they um
sort it very well
one of the things is this if you look to
the right of the sorted population we
get
a lot of cells that i believe were
correctly sorted and i think might be
that spreading we see might be a
function of
some subtleties in the unmixing that
we're looking at now i'll come back to
that
and here is the ones i didn't show in
the original plot or in the original
presentation so here we took the
dendritic cells we didn't really have
that many
and if we look at them versus a c11v
versus cd19
sure enough there they are we're getting
no
b-cell contaminants so the sort's
working these are cells that are just
probably starting to die a little bit so
you can also look at the
mhc2
again c11c and sure enough we still see
the same relative distribution i believe
that sort worked i just believe there's
not enough cells in it to make a really
pretty picture but from a functional
sorting point of view that totally
worked
and the least pretty one
was the neutrophils there just wasn't
that many that that lived
okay because they were just sitting in
an inappropriate buffer for too long but
you can see of the little bit that we
had
they actually sorted
cleanly once again there was no there
was a lot of b cell contaminants and we
looked at the ly6g it was basically all
all positive for that so i believe that
those sorts work so this was
six way sorting
done on a
23 color panel
and the analysis done on a separate
platform
okay
i think i'm one of the few people around
that has the ability to do that and
because there's a lot of pressure on me
to explain how all this works
okay so i want to come back to
where we're at so far
okay so some of the conclusions are
really basic
spectral sorting
on the bigfoot works
i mean the workflow works really good
and
the validation of the controls during
the process of when you're running your
controls on the system
keeps you from getting yourself in a
weird place it's ensuring that
your color choice and your controls
allow for proper fixing so there's a
built-in qc in the system
the target cells they showed you for
were sorted correctly with high purity
i mean the ability to look on a
different analyzer and a different
platform and say
yes that works
that's uh that's really important to me
and assorted populations while there
might have been some viability issues to
the way we handled the experiment
there's no real evidence of
contamination with other cell types to
suggest that the sort did not work i 100
percent in the utter confidence believe
this machine sorts correctly
now
here's the
not pretty side of where we're at right
now
i'm sorry no that comes next scratch
that proof of principle experiments were
performed independently
panel design reagent choices were
determined independently the instrument
setups were just done by us i basically
sat with
myself one of my
sword operators and the postdoc and we
did it we didn't have an army of support
people and applications people you know
hold their hands to do it it was done by
us
and
you know the automation of software has
allowed for users to
make these experiments ahead of time and
know that they have potential to work
just by virtue of plugging it in
beforehand assessing that so right now
i'm sure this sorter works
and
the workflow keeps you from painting
yourself in the corner too badly
but future can
future considerations
are big and this is where we're at right
now and i think this is where
the next great
drive and flow will be will be
comparison
of these different spectral platforms
because for a while it was all defined
by
scitec with their aurora and that thing
delivered amazingly but now
we have the bigfoot and now sony has
their new id system which is a super
high dimensional spectral system
and the amount of effort and resources
it takes to be able to compare these
things
is really limiting there's not that many
places that have
more than one of each of those three
systems
let alone three of them so the idea of a
great cross comparison where we can do
one experiment
and look at it in all three platforms
and then debate the nuances in the
unmixing platform
or the unmissing algorithms that's we're
going to be
going forward this is a really really
complex space
and we only we've only looked through it
through one lens until now now that
we're looking through the second lens
it's opening up a lot of questions
okay there are differences we're seeing
differences both good and bad sometimes
you see more spreading on one machine
than the other and sometimes the
opposite is true for the other machine
sometimes one machine looks better in
one channel but not the other
and is it a function of the hardware i
know
bigfoot uses photomultiplier tubes
uh scitec uses
uh photodiodes
and then
i believe um
sony uses its own special photo
multiplier tube with its own dispersive
array so those are three different light
detection methodologies are they having
an impact on the differences
reagent and panel cross control cross
compatibility that's the giant hurdle
right now because everyone's designing
their platforms off the aurora
and i can already tell some reagents
work better on the aurora and some work
better
on the bigfoot and actually defining
those and being able to
make
an iterative panel builder that works
across both platforms would be a really
good next step and that's kind of what
we're working on
and there could be differences in the
unmixing algorithms okay that's what
we're digging right now and uh i have
some really cool data sets that i have
just not had just acquired recently in
the past few weeks that range from 12 to
24 colors that have been done
on both platforms and now we all have to
go through that data and there are some
differences and we have discussed why
those differences are and whether it
actually impacts uh the end results
and finally one of the great ones this
is happening even in the analytical side
what's the difference
in the controls do cellular controls
versus feed controls make a real
difference in the way the data is
unmixed and does that
issue propagate the more you use one or
the other that's working on now
so i believe i i want to call this part
one of spectral flow part two will be
looking at all these future
considerations and i have the data in my
hands but
dealing with all this
and spending the time to run these super
elegant experiments is complicated it
requires
researchers to do their experiments in
triplicates to look at three different
platforms
and that's and also the addition of
other sets of controls where it's fmos
or single biological stains things like
that just to assess the differences
across the different platforms the
unmixing that's a lot of resources and
time required to do that and that's what
we're working on now and i have
three good data sets now that i hope to
show in the next either next talk or
hopefully i'll see all you guys face to
face in a meeting in the future and can
start showing this
and with that i'm going to kind of wrap
up here
thank my crew brian seeger's the sword
manager he is just on top of making sure
runs brian monteverde who is my senior
full operator who has bonded with the
bigfoot and his workflow through the
software and his recognition of little
if things are right or not right has
become kind of
just next level divine he's really good
at it and uh alfons who uh helps keep
the rest of the lab running while we're
all doing this uh
bleeding edge type work and finally
landon for the um
work he did with the cigleck research
and what he helped to set up these
initial panels
and going forward i'm working with uh
luke hayton in the immunology department
and we have a lot of really cool stuff i
hope to show you guys soon and then
finally
bigfoot support
uh i can't thank tdar enough for
recognizing uh the opportunity to work
with us angie gold gold fannie has
basically been
the mother hand of helping keeping all
of us crazy scientists and researchers
all coordinated and and down a pathway
towards productivity nick rohrbacher the
the mathematician who's doing all the
work with the unmixing and helps us
unravel when we have issues that are
unclear
uh mitch durham who's one of the
lead engineers who helps us remotely
whenever we're in trouble one click text
to mitch and he's up on the machine
looking at it for us from his couch in
colorado because we're usually calling
him late and then finally they just got
kelly gunston as they're one of their
application people and her knowledge of
spectral panel building and spectral
troubleshooting has been really useful
to us
thank you alan for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question
here is
have you noticed any differences in the
spectral unmixing method between the
bigfoot and the aurora since you have
both
okay well like that's right to the point
there
the answer is yes
and
we're as i said before we have
originally we were doing
we went big original first kind of
replicative experiments were
23 and 24 color
and
that's a lot and as you start looking at
little variances in that you're not sure
is it
is it
panel design issues is it one machine or
the other
and we're kind of
trying to un
unravel this stuff because we are seeing
differences in some cases i'm seeing
bigger spreading in some channels on the
auroras and i'm not seeing it as bad on
the bigfoot
in other cases i'm seeing
stuff that's not as bright on the
bigfoot that looks great on the aurora
so it's come to the conclusion that
it's kind of an apples and oranges
situations i think a panel optimized for
the aurora is not going to be optimal
for the
bigfoot and vice versa so right now one
of our current quests
is to come up with maybe 15 colors that
you know is going to work great on both
and that's what we're moving towards now
the 12 color panel we have uh that i'm
looking at from the taton lab looks like
it might meet that and we're seeing some
little subtle differences in the
unmixing and that's kind of what we're
working on right now
so
i don't know if i can answer that
question i can say yes there are
differences i can't
answer them in
full confident detail yet because i know
there are differences
but i need to be able to say why and
that's what i'm working on right now i
think that is the german question here
because scitec has defined what spectral
should look like
and we don't know yet whether maybe
bigfoot sees it different or maybe
there's some ground in between that's
actually optimal and that's what we're
trying to figure out now
thank you alan our next question here is
since you used both beads and cells for
the single color controls did you find
an advantage with one or the other
yeah another great question and the
answer is yes with an asterisk next to
it i mean no one can deny beads are the
way easier control
okay
they're
they're bright
and they'll do whatever antibody that
the use of a biological control
isn't always possible some epitopes just
aren't expressed at high enough level to
give you a good on mixing okay they're
gonna be either too few or too bright at
the higher levels and you can't just
swap
you know reagents because the tandems
aren't exactly the same that that really
becomes obvious in
in spectral space
so
right now i think in a perfect world
and we have one group that's doing it
they're trying to do everything with
with
cellular controls
but what we've done in some recent
experiments some of the data we have
we've done it with cellular
and
beads and look at it both ways using the
beads of the unmixing and the cellular
and to see how whether it affects the
the
unmixing of the controls and that's what
i'm working on right now
one of the issues with bigfoot i know
it's being fixed right now is that when
you run your controls
you aren't able to visualize them
afterwards they're just basically
processed in the unmixing algorithm
and that's that
you don't actually save them as a sample
so we've gone back and then run the
controls as a sample which takes a lot
of work in a 22 color panel
and uh
and that's what we're looking at right
now yes i believe i can't say yet i
believe there are subtle differences
that have to be
looked at but i don't think
one or the other makes or breaks an
experiment i think they can be used
together and i think as long as you're
defining your autofluorescence with with
whatever cell type you're using you're
probably going to be okay but once again
this is some of the bleeding edge stuff
that we're trying to figure out now i
know scitec's looking at it as well and
i know i think in some communications
maria issues like in certain areas of
spectrum
beads and cells can behave a little
differently
thank you alan looks like we have time
for one more question
any advice on transferring panels from
your spectral analyzer to the bigfoot oh
my gosh these questions like the
trifecta of oh my god needs more work i
don't know
you know and that's what we're doing now
like i said we've hit on that 11 color
and i think what the next step to do
would be an iterative panel building
you can go with
what's going to work best to a certain
point you're gonna be able to get to
what works best on both machines before
you have to start bifurcate into going
adding this color will work better on
this machine or to work better on that
machine
and i can tell you right now
in
probably in 15 or 20 colors you're going
to start seeing a panel's gonna work
better for one
or the other so there's going to be
a lot of work done and unfortunately i'm
not capable of doing it all and i know
other people are kind of ramping up to
where we are right now there's going to
be
panel design optimization
for the bigfoot i think right now
everything's optimized for the scitec
and we've been trying to walk in those
same footprints
and it's just not quite the same and so
i think the work on us now for people
who want to do the big sorting on the
bigfoot is figuring out where
where the commonality
splits and what reagents are better
biased towards the disorder platform
thank you alan do you have any final
comments for our audience
yeah this is part one this is
unfortunately i was had to give i was
told i would give this talk i said i
would give this talk
and i'm sitting on a pile of data that
would answer all these questions
and i'm dying to dig deep into it and i
think
really these data sets will help answer
those last three questions better than
anything i'm showing you now
and i do believe
spectral is totally the way to go future
forward and high dimensional flow i
think the bigfoot's an amazing platform
and i love the competition in this space
between scitec thermo and sony to all
have these high dimensional spectral
systems
and i'm impressed by what i what i've
seen so far and the next i think in the
next couple years we're seeing the same
growth we saw when we switched from
analog to digital now we're switching
from classical to spectral and that's
what the future is
thank you again alan salek for your time
today and for your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye